i'm larry goldstein
i'm a professor of cellular and
molecular medicine at uc san diego
and i have the great pleasure today to
interview my friend
colleague comrade in arms paul berg
nobel prize winner and also a recipient
of the public policy award from the
american society for cell biology
i'm going to ask paul some questions
about his life as a science policy
advocate
and public figure so paul thank you for
taking the time to join me today
thank you good so so let's start at the
beginning
you had a very illustrious career in
science
but something made you decide to
leave the lab at least part of the time
and engage in
policy debates what was it that brought
you out for the first time
well it certainly wasn't voluntary
it turned out that an experiment which
we had planned and were in the midst of
elicited a lot of concern amongst other
scientists
the experiment we had in progress was to
fuse a small
mini chromosome of containing lambda
lambda genes
and three genes of e coli the gal operon
and we fuse that with sv40 to make a
recombinant that contain
now this recombinant could propagate in
e coli
because it contained the parts on the
mini plasmid which allowed it to
propagate
e coli and it could also be propagated
and transfect
mammalian cells so it was kind of a dual
headed thing and what we wanted to do is
to be able to make mutations
in the sv40 genome in coli and then test
them
in mammalian cells and the other thing
we were going to test and see whether
the gal genes could be expressed in
mammals right so that was the idea of
the experiment
the point was that we were going to be
propagating
sv40 genes in e coli right right so the
concern was
coli is a natural inhabitant in humans
and the concern was
inadvertently could you in fact humans
with the
e coli you were propagating and could
that possibly lead to cancer right
that was the concern and depending upon
where you came down on the topic you
were either vociferous about it
yeah or you were just saying forget
about it it's not serious
okay but i soon after a lot of
consultations i said
became convinced that i could not
dismiss the risk and make
zero likelihood and so i thought well
we'll just put it on the shelf and so
the whole thing died down
yeah a year later or not
quite a year later janet mertz a
graduate student in my lab
discovered that eco r1 made cohesive
ends and she discovered that she could
take any two dnas and join them together
and so stan cohn and her boyer then
began to actually
make a lot of recombinants using e coli
plasmids right
and checking drug resistance and showing
that they can make chimeric dna
molecules
and they talked about it at a gordon
conference and that
elicited the same kind of response
amongst a small minority of the audience
who said oh my god you guys can really
make some dangerous things
so what happens is at that gordon
conference they got maxine singer
and dieter saul who were the co-chairs
to draft a letter
to the academy and to publish that
letter in science
calling attention to the great promise
that being able to make
new kinds of dna molecules uh but also
calling attention to possible
dangers and risks right and when the
president of the academy got this
letter he said what do i do with it and
maxine said to him
call paul berg he's thought about this
problem
right and so he asked me
would i put together a group of people
that could advise the academy on how to
respond to the concerns
that had been raised and
so i did i put together a small group
and we met
at mit dave baltimore dan nathan's
myself jim watson a few other
norton zinder people who would
understand
the nature of the problem we met for a
whole day as group
and in the end there was no advice that
we could provide we didn't know what to
do
so we said you know literally you could
pick up the phone and call everybody
of your scientific community who's
likely to use the technology and say
hey be careful yup but we couldn't do
that so we said well the next best thing
is why don't we just
publish a letter in science
calling attention to the promise to some
of the potential risks that have been
raised
and essentially
calling essentially asking the
the scientific community to put a short
hold
on three kinds of experiments we didn't
call for a moratorium
all this kind of work there was three
kinds of experiments that we
specifically
called attention to and in the letter we
proposed having an international
conference
some six or eight months later to
examine the risks in more detail
and come forward with some
recommendations i think the scientific
community got a lot of
good kudos from the public right saying
here's the problem
scientists call it attention you
actually got out of it
how to how to deal with this thing yeah
so
if you look back now you say i got into
public policy
through my own experiments yeah and just
being called on
to say what do we do yeah when somebody
raised the risk so
the initial so-called moratorium letter
which came out of the group
uh called for a meeting
to deal with it and so we convened i was
the chair of convening the
syllabar meeting and the organizing
committee was maxine dave baltor myself
zinder sydney brenner we had a person
from europe
and we were going to organize a meeting
of experts to try to assess
what was the magnitude of the risks what
was the likelihood of
them coming true and how could we
proceed
in any case okay so the syllabar meeting
was a major event 150
people huge representation from the
media which was probably one of the best
things we decided
there were 15 people from press and
newspapers magazines and so on
and in those three days we debated
what are the kinds of experiments you
want to do what are the possible risks
and we organized it very well so the
meeting was not all talking about risks
it was talking about science and that
was probably a saving grace to the
why the meeting succeeded because people
came prepared to talk about scientific
experiments
and they were balanced by discussion
there's a lot of interesting science
came out of the
syllabar meeting yeah one was the safe
bug
to engineer a microbe right which could
not escape from the lab
right okay so the crippled host the
crippled host right and the second one
was actually
so that was sydney brenner's idea it's a
good idea he brought that
to the meeting and and i think that was
turned people around a lot because
suddenly
we could answer the question that you
could devise the experiments in some way
which would markedly lessen the
likelihood of escape
so this organism wouldn't be able to
live outside the lab
okay so there were a number so right in
that meeting
you could see science taking over
people beginning with well we could do
this well and i think you and i would
agree
if you're going to have good science
policy it has to be
driven by good science right
misunderstanding is not going to get the
job done
the turning point of the meeting frankly
was the last night
when the lawyers had their session oh
and the ethicists yeah we'd invited a
group of lawyers and ethicists and did
the lawyers and ethicists sit through
the sciences
they participated in everything as did
the press yeah the press were free to
ask questions raise points
and in the drinking in the evenings they
milled around
and they were full members of the
of the meeting the lawyers pointed out
the legal problems right and challenged
jim watson with the idea because he had
now
turned and he was totally opposed to any
kind of regulation
right whereas he'd been a signer of the
original letter
um they said we'll close down
people could close down cold spring
harbor if there's any danger or anything
that happens
and then people's own personal risks
were beginning to
played on and eventually i think
everybody says we cannot walk out of
here
tomorrow morning saying we don't have
any advice
right so that much especially with the
press there because they were going to
cover it right and that night
i maxine and dave and sydney we drafted
a set of guidelines and recommended that
the nih
use this as a as a sort of outline for a
set of guidelines that would essentially
determine the conditions under which
this research could be done and on the
conditions of which
should not be done and so the whole
thing that came out was very positive we
debated it
and voted on segment by segment until
when
noon came when we had to leave we had an
approved
list of regular was it unanimous or was
it no no there were
i would say it was 95 that's pretty good
pretty amazing going forward even though
the language was
muddled and things like that but we all
agree that we would
smooth things out so i worked on the
language
and dave did and maxine and we finally
got
a document which is now recorded as a
famous document
out of the cilamar conference we look
back on it would say you know we
a bunch of amateurs yeah we mumbled
through a bunch of stuff we made some
decisions
that were smart in retrospect for
example one of the things we did not do
and did not include in anywhere's agenda
was the ethics
we didn't talk about right genetic
testing we didn't talk
about that right we talked about real
experiments
and what the impact of those experiments
would be in the field so the agriculture
nitrogen fixation you know people had
all kinds of ideas
of what we call the low-hanging fruit
what was the thing the infamous
low-lagging treatments
yeah right all of those things were
obvious in retrospect when you look back
you say
most of what's happened nobody even
could conceive about
plus nine yeah and so you know
that's the way science goes you make a
slight breakthrough you got a lot of
very smart people out there very smart
people figure out very quickly how to
use
this new notion new tool or whatever
and the field explodes and that's what's
happened yeah
and why recombinant dna is fantastic so
when
when did the congress get into the act
when did the politicians decide that
this was something they should worry
about
okay so the the congress the
sulmar meeting was held in february of
1975
uh the rest of that year there were
small groups that were meeting to devise
the
guidelines the guidelines came out in
the summer of 76
and that ruled today and then
sniping occurred and the sniping
occurred from different people
who said well these guidelines are not
rigorous enough or we don't trust the
scientists to abide by them
congress began to respond to these
little
barbs and they said on a course that
they were actually going to prohibit
recombinant dna
research in the country and i remember
spending a lot of time in congress and i
can remember
vividly one senator from arkansas
who's normally a liberal and was a
pretty good guy getting up
and saying on the floor of the senate
i never got through high school
chemistry and i don't profess to
understand any of this science
but i believe this is the most dangerous
work ever undertaken
in this country and i would recommend
prohibiting it there were a lot of
people who shared that view
and i am cynical enough to now realize
that what changed the whole picture yeah
and obliterated the concerns
was the founding of genentech and the
first days
stock issue ah money suddenly
it became clear that this was going to
be a commercial
right energy and important and to put
any prohibitions on it was like
shooting yourself in the foot and the
whole thing disappeared so the promise
of making insulin for kids was not the
winning message you think or it was a
message but when you actually saw
something happen
yes that was no longer virtual i believe
that was the thing that actually
interesting was a switch and the
atmosphere
changed completely as soon as it became
a couple of companies
starting up to take advantage of this
technology to do this that and the other
thing
so ultimately the resolution of this was
if i understand if i remember correctly
no law was ever passed in the congress
no law was ever passed
and it was all done by scientists
driving
the development of good regulation
through the funding bodies which then
spread
exactly amazing it's a fantastic example